[Music]
the expanse is obviously one of those
universes that has a ton of opportunity
to tell great stories one of the things
i'm super excited about is the zero g
stuff that we've been doing a big part
of when we're making the game not only
are we thinking about the characters we
also have to think about how can we
evolve the genre in any way or that will
make players excited to be part of this
universe and feel like they're engaging
in something rather than just being a
passive audience member he'll figure
something out i know you will
it's actually been a really interesting
thing as an actor to explore some of her
more
vulnerable sides that by the time we
meet her in the series they've been
cauterized
because this score drummer
this is the greatest score any scavenger
has ever come across
you'll need me if you want any chance of
unloading it
the craziness of a exploded ship that
now constitutes several parts in a mass
you can move among
and balancing that out against
almost like you're excavating the story
that's a personal story those are people
those are characters and you are now
among
their ghosts whatever they were doing
right before they died being a scavenger
pretty dark job
we're really excited about how it feels
to both play and experience the story in
the
is long gone and we game have a ship
that's ready to be scavenged
so get to it
[Applause]